[Musique]
bonjour maïté quel est le menu du festin
a aujourd'hui on va faire une mine
malaya et quoi d'autre et des beignets
de sardines arbitres mois et demi mâle à
la femme sonne un peu tiède voilà les
templiers
mettez vous promener un petit peu non
mais j'avais des photos et vous avez
envie de découvrir la cuisine d'ailleurs
un tout petit peu oui exactement de
faire le tour du monde un petit peu pas
d'être toujours encline à rion des
landes et on va faire tout le tour en
fait c'est parce que dans tout les pays
y as dragon délicieux il faut dire que
la cuisine créole elle est bien connue
dans notre pays depuis longtemps donc il
faut pas oublier que la femme de
bonaparte elle venait de la barre à la
tia josée simon alors joséphine de
beauharnais voilà elle a porté la mode
de la cuisine créole en france déjà au
siècle dernier
n'est ce pas les épices les poissons et
crustacés ses épices et la balle c'est
bien oui mais chez nous on a tous ces
beaux poissons se prenent aquitaine on a
tous ces crustacés
alors c'est bien pour ça qu'on va
essayer une recette créole cela dit elle
s'appelait pas tout à fait une alaïa
pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez appelé
malaria des m20 micheline et m me
connecter mais voilà on avoir l'envié me
maladière ballon et on va se marier à
créole alors qu'est ce qu'il nous faut
pour ça il nous faut du jambon il nous
faut de la ventrèche et nous faut des
poivrons des petits oignons ou des
oignons du citron vert de l'aïe des
tomates du thym du riz et à la créole
évidemment des petits piments parce
qu'il faut bien relever sort du paprika
bien entendu des basques ont alors je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on a des pattes de
crabes font venir jouer à wii j'ai en
moi et sont en cours parce qu'on est sûr
de vous en trouverez partout on va se la
sont particulièrement belles et elles
sont aquitaine mais pourrait être
antillais voilà des langoustines là
qu'est ce que vous nous avez mis des
supers de clermont à la clamoux je
cherche le mont blanc et puis pour
l'autre recette est donc désormais nos
lits
petites sardines des petits royaumes
usant son petit plusieurs sont bonnes
des jolis arbres à la tête et par quoi
commence temps par ce fameux plats
créoles le mime à la guerre et qu'est ce
que vous allez faire en premier eh bien
j'ai coupé mes pauvres en petits dés et
j'imagine que vous allez les faire
revenir dans une poêle
mais d'abord je vais faire mes lardons
ah ben c'est pas une poêle c'est une
cocotte entre une cocotte où vous avez
mis quoi dans la graisse ou de lui le ce
qu'on veut la ssii vise lui le passionné
aujourd'hui
maintenant je vais y mettre les
habitants du rire à tout prix peut
déconner quand même
oui mais ça va de soi d'abord l'annoncé
de la ventrèche qui était sale et pointe
laissons pas oublier la petite brèche
après de l'huile de l'oignon rognons
voilà voilà ensuite quoi je vais mettre
mon âge que je vais écrasé un petit peu
comme toujours à la main vaut mieux que
ça donne un meilleur sucre sur cette île
est un peu écrasée regarde tout ça garde
tout le tout de touche c'est bien comme
ça ouais voilà allez on l'a maintenant
les poivrons et bien les voilà il a
peut-être d'autres bons coups il nourrit
d'ailleurs mettre un petit peu moins et
ça va faire joli petit ragoût vous allez
voir ça tient et ça sera bien magnifique
pour vous tout y est un peu tout ça bien
entendu pour que ça prenne jeu et même
un petit peu de poids oui voilà à et
ensuite on va continuer
quand une autre source la géométrie à
wana le riz il vient là notre fameux riz
créole vous le mettez dans y'a de la
grèce et des légumes très chaud les deux
il va revenir il à les applaudir et leur
prendre un peu de couleurs parce que moi
j'ai lu dans des livres qu'on appelait
le riz à la créole quand on le faisait
d'abord revenir dans une matière
chauveau alors maintenant à puisque ces
eaux du terme
un petit peu bingo oui un tout petit peu
la dose rate ça ça va bien parfumée
finir de parfumer vont ensuite puisque
ses créoles
il faut voter oui dont elie 110 peu avec
des petits
hilmar maintenant il faut remettre et à
la crise cette cuisine créole c'est très
agréable même en aquitaine parce qu'il
fait souvent chaud et à bordeaux et fait
même chaud et humide alors c'est donc le
mât un peu antillais et s'est placé très
agréable à manger dans des pays chauds
et humides ou dans les régions désignées
alors chaude et huilée tomates on va
mettre les tomates et là c'est pareil
pour tous et non se seraient trouvés
regardez-moi ça attention parce que vous
avez en bas les autres beaucoup de
choses à mettre dedans son père de
l'avoir je n'étais pas très dynamique
comme ça va diminuer
non non non non la bon on ne sait jamais
je sois vous avez regardé tout tout tout
petit cube devoir payer jambon de pays
puisqu'il ya la ventrèche maintenant on
va mettre les jambes et sa clique éviter
parce que c'est c'est comment il faut un
meurtre mais c'est un très très bon
jambon de pays le basque ou la commune y
feront des hôpitaux ou me donner tout
mais oui
mettez-vous m'inquiéter mais non mais
non mangera beaucoup de choses encore à
rajouter non vous inquiétez pas avec du
bouillon ça va aller ça va diminuer ça
ça va faire plus et de l'eau vous allez
voir
bon je vous laisse entre anvers et voilà
c'est prêt c'est ce citron un brin de
mamers de presse au citron et moi j'ai
des gros semaine où on doute pas de
votre force la série voilà on est
tranquille on n'est pas un délire la
région n'est pas inquiet du tout et
voilà ça ça va donner à notre bon ou pas
cela va aussi mettre le citron en servez
vous du citron là après ensuite c'est
l'époque vous avez déjà mis et vous
avons réparé quoi là je crois que ça
c'est du paprika pic alors merci au site
spécial de là bas on en met un peu
partout voilà ça va donner de jolies
petites couleurs on avait très bien très
bien pourquoi notre l'outiller je vais
mettre en route mais quand même je vais
mettre mon fumée
il sera ce baromètre poisson que vous
aviez préparé à l'avant à l'avance
toujours pareil et il faut toujours
garder traite du vin blanc oui et d'une
union et tout ça alors
et on a vingt minutes de cuisson et là
deux rives a gonflé tout va cuire en
même temps et bien sûr c'est bon pare
feu avant ce mélange et voilà anne un
petit peu plus parce que ça va il faut
pas toujours sec c'est bon fight et je
veux le dire et mijoté un petit peu là
on aura le temps de préparer les
crustacés qu'est-ce qu'il faut ajouter
sahraouis mais couvrir parce que ça va
très vite prendre la voie là je vais
couvrir un petit peu et pendant ce temps
qu'est ce que vous leur faites dans ces
halos but nous avons là la cellule avant
ses lacets les perses de crainte que je
vais couper à vous allumez les ai cassé
un peu délicat c'est pour tout ça donne
vient d'ouvrir sa part fumait bien
reculer robuste voilà un petit coup sec
et il en est bien la plus grande mais
très vous le rajouter avec vos légumes
oui simplement attention et vous allez
voir que ça vaille contenir tout ça et
là regardez moi ça si c'est beau ça fait
deux bonnes petites sauces si ça alors
ça on va la mettre dedans
là on va mettre nos langoustines entière
bien sûr mais bien sûr la savait que ça
faire jolie place s'est lancée dans la
région je vous avais dit que ce serait
juste neil non on va tous ne vous
inquiétez pas là je vais remuer bien ça
va aller et par là dessus je suis sûr
que vous allez mettre vos grosses clame
pour qu'elle s'ouvre à la chaleur oui la
remise à nettoyer sans nettoyait
évidemment bien brossés bien nettoyé
dans l'eau salée et voilà et regardez
moi ça et on va mettre le couvercle et
tout va bien et mijoter pendant quoi une
petite demi-heure une hutte demi heure
on ira regarder ce qui se passe alors
maïté en attendant peut-être faire
l'autre recette c'est à dire les bègues
et beignets le sort bine bien sûr et
comment faites-vous cette pâte à beignet
prevacid des oeufs
on sait par les blancs des jaunes alors
il faut de royan 9
et puis on met un avanthier tiens je
vais tout de suite attendez attendez 1,9
entier et deux journées dont deux jaunes
oui voilà ça y va d'ailleurs blanc deux
côtés de blanc de compter que je vais
monter en neige tout à l'heure aux
banques
je prends mon fou et le tout bien
entendu deux journées à 2 centimes je
mets ma farine
ces mesures et écouter les proportions
qu'on veut mettre du sel et du poivre
ça aussi mais tesa bon alors vous avez
pas besoin de mesurer parce que vous
êtes si 60 hectares a coûté à l'oeil à
la main si vous voulez vous mettez un
verre de un petit bol de farine
vous voyez ça c'est de la bière alors un
petit verre de bière way aller allons-y
vous allez voir écouter pour nos amis la
première fois si laraque n'a ratons pas
2.0 bienvenus s'ils ont mis tant les
arts ea nous paraissait la boue ne vous
inquiétez pas exactement celui n'est
qu'à casser de trois fois et ça y est le
tout c'est de voir comment c'est comme
c'est terminé et honte aux yeux regardez
là impeccable
bah ça se mélange tout seul c'est
fabriqué et la bière c'est mieux que le
nerf de dire si c'est pas pareil mais
c'est pour la protéger c'est pas pareil
et voilà c'est mélanger c'est pour eux
voilà alors il faut la laisser reposer
quand même une oeuvre et pendant qu'elle
repose vous allez faire les filets voilà
falloir bien difficile de demander mieux
a redit non j'ai coupé la tête
oui je les appelais évident de les vider
vous prenez la queue on sentait quand ça
craque heures voilà pour la tournée et
vous tirez
voilà ça a l'air facile et après ça
c'est formidable et on va faire deux
autres allaient paraît même opération
toc toc toc dire que c'est un marchand
de poisson maïté vous êtes vertueuse
sérieux voilà on en a fait qu elle
coordonne ainsi c'est au théâtre avec sa
voix tient note pad on suppose qu'elle a
reposé suffisamment vous avez battu les
blancs en neige trentaine et maintenant
il faut mélanger ça aussi avec une main
d'artistes mais voilà comme ça il faut
pas faire n importe comment va tourner
ses voeux sans dessus dessous comme son
nom il faut encore voir leblanc gentil
marge gens qui n'en laissant de lait
voilà j'en ai fait à ses loyers we can a
largement dépassé largement en france
quand vous avez évidemment mis une poêle
sur le feu avec de l'huile avec de
l'huile bonjour et oui parce que ces
derniers dont il faut ça baigne
voilà ma petite micheline oui et alors
maintenant l'huile est chaude et chaude
vous croyez que ça va aller je le
souhaite de tout mon coeur je prends une
sourdine
je la prends dans la pâte avec vienne 30
par là que je ne montre ce monsieur
voilà et après hop ça va grésillés maïté
voulait en faire une autre
bien sûr vous les avez roulé en boule à
rouler en boule et hop c'est beau ça
c'est inhabituel à cette orgie mari
quand même ces petits pâtés de sable il
faut pas te reverrai pas marcher là
qu'une entrée voilà regardez c'est joli
et puis voilà et puis ça y est et bien
nos plans vont être près où il n'y aura
plus qu elle est présentée avec les
beignets auront bien dorer sous toutes
les formes
l'ami malaga peut être servi dans sa
cocotte c'est bien sympa on sort de tout
fret
alors elle est toute belle avec toutes
les classes ouvertes et puis là dessus
aujourd'hui de regarder bail à l'arrivée
mélangez a saoulé
ça fait une jardinière de légumes et
nous ordinaire verbe langoustines ça
c'est délicieux sympathique et puis là
on a nous voilà nos filets de sardines
aux beignets de filets de sardines qui
sont dissociées de plats maison très
différents les sardines typiquement
aquitain l'ami malaya un mélange
d'aquitaine et de créole
des plats d'été surtout on peut dire et
bien essayé c'est bon au revoir bientôt
au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]